Welcome back to the David Pakman Show.
Let's get right back to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 forty seven fifty.
Let's go to our caller from these 7 1 8.
Area code caller from 7 1 8.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
But Jenny from New York.
Hey, J.D., what's up?
A specific question has the capacity of the
U.S., in your opinion, to provide the opportunities
for a healthy, safe and prosperous life in
the years ahead.
Substantially diminished post-hardcore up
to I ask, is a well-traveled person and a
first generation American and a person of
color who works remotely in I.T. currently.
And I'm prepared to emigrate out of America
after travel restrictions are lifted.
Separately, speaking to relatives who work
in health care in New York and the D.C. areas,
I fear that the worst of this Aaskov to pandemic
here in the US is ahead of us, not behind
us.
Hopefully you can.
Some of my fears and frustrations, but thank
you for everything you do, David Pakman.
Well, listen.
I mean, here's the deal, Jadie.
The pandemic itself at some point is going
to pass and there's going to be irreparable
health harm that is done to what could be
hundreds of thousands of people that die.
We don't really know what the death toll will
be, but it seems like, you know, within a
month it could be over 100000.
And then who knows how high it's going to
go in the U.S.? Eventually we're going to
get past it and the economy will start to
recover.
But what we've learned from this is that even
an economy that looks pretty solid and I talked
about this on yesterday's program is pretty
fragile, right?
It's pretty damn fragile.
I mean, the stock market was near record highs,
unemployment near record lows.
We had consumer confidence was was relatively
high, inflation under control, etc., etc.
And eight in eight weeks, we've lost 21 percent
of the workforce, 21 percent of the workforce
has lost their jobs.
There are people without health insurance.
There are people who are in food lines.
So I don't know that the pandemic will actually
change the reality of this fragile economy.
But the pandemic has exposed how fragile even
a seemingly good economy can be.
And that is something that I'm guessing people
are going to remember the rest of their lives.
Thank you, David.
All right.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Let's go next to our caller from the 7 5 7
area code, who's calling today from 7 5 7.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, that's you.
Hey, David, this is an Sanford Ginia.
Aaron, I'm Robin Green.
I'll get a caller in.
Let me just mention.
So we're having this issue with the phone
system where when people talk loud, it actually
creates a paper crunching noise.
And I can't control that on my end.
So maybe just put the phone like a couple
inches further from your face and then I think
you'll come in beautifully.
That's actually better.
That is so much better.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm reading his article.
I watched the post about Trump installing
this Republican donors to the Postmaster-General
position.
Yes.
And I really I just got two questions.
One is there isn't any argument that Trump
has that maybe Amazon isn't paying enough
for the delivery and I corporate's paying
enough for delivery 30, you or even a German
argument about that.
There is the argument that.
So let me address that.
Amazon makes deals with multiple carriers,
so I'm not an expert on shipping and logistics.
But from what I understand, Amazon, I believe
Amazon in the U.S. only uses U.P.S..
I don't think they do FedEx, although I may
be wrong, but my understanding is that in
the U.S., Amazon cuts a deal with U.P.S. where
they are not literally paying for every package
the way you or I might if we send a few packages
a month.
My understanding is that it's a combination
of fixed fee deals plus some other amounts.
So Amazon and other large shippers have always
struck deals with shippers where if you only
look at the per package price, it might seem
like it's a loss, but you need to look at
the value of the total contract.
So my point is, I don't know that what Trump
is saying tells us the whole picture.
But I would need to investigate it more.
OK.
And it's just the sense having this Republican
appointee in a position to control people
voting by mail.
That's just twisting election.
Yeah, this is pretty scary when I'm president.
We have got to think about this.
Yeah.
So unfortunately, pretty dangerous Trump.
So Trump fires inspectors general who are
going to look into things that he doesn't
want looked into.
Trump bullies departments into getting rid
of people that are opposed to what Donald
Trump wants to do.
So unfortunately, this is a situation where
between a rock and a hard place, because the
only solution is to remove Trump in November.
And yet Donald Trump is taking steps like
appointing a friendly postmaster general who
may be able to assist in not having vote by
mail work.
So one way would be it's going to be up to
states to decide about vote by mail.
You could have a state say, hey, we're going
to do vote by mail.
And then the postmaster general can generate
a paper which says, hey, you know what, the
post office would not be able to properly
handle all of Florida voting by mail.
And they can create all of this fear, uncertainty
and doubt to put it in question whether we're
going to do it.
So unfortunately, our only solution is to
remove Trump.
And Trump is actually putting people in power
who may hamper our ability to do that.
I don't have an answer.
It's dystopian and nightmarish and you're
right to point it out.
It even seems like he could just, you know,
gosh, and had them both.
Lives, they shut it down.
And then they went.
I wouldn't put it past a postal service.
I don't know what the logistics of that would
be, but I would I wouldn't put anything past
Trump to at least attempt at this point in
time.
And he knows vote by mail would be terrible
for him.
And he's going to try to prevent it from happening
at least in swing states where where it could
flip the results.
Wow, PRITZKER Yeah, my pleasure.
Thanks, David.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.